j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public direction l'Ukraine avec ce
constat depuis un an malgré des
centaines de milliers de morts et de
blessés des deux côtés le front n'a
quasiment pas bougé la Russie contrôle
plus de 17 % du territoire ukrainien
avant de demander à nos experts si un
vainqueur peut sortir des prochains mois
de combat notre reportage à Kief
Jonathan Dupri Fabien REER et Maxime
zatsef se sont rendus dans cette ville
avec une délégation sénatoriale C il y a
quelques jours à la rencontre d'une
population toujours uni contre
l'envahisseur
russe keV après bientôt 2 ans de guerre
à l'image du pays la capitale
ukrainienne se tient toujours debout
face à Moscou en plein centrre-eville au
milieu des passants des véhicules
militaires russes détruit sont exposés
comme des trophées symbole de la
résistance d'un pays qui fait bloc face
à
l'envahisseur je suis persuadé que nous
tiendrons jusqu'au bout soudés comme les
doigts de la main
est inébranlable nous sommes ukrainiens
et nous tiendrons ensem jusqu'au dernier
on est une nation
forte à proximité des épaves militaires
le mur des héros rend hommage au
milliers de soldat mort pour la patrie
depuis 2014 Maria a récemment perdu de
cousins à la guerre pour elle ce ser ne
sera pas
V quand on voit toutes ces photos on dit
qu'on pas le droit de baisser les BR
tout ce
P on pas le choix il faut
tenir K est à 600 km de la ligne de
front mais la guerre y est omniprésente
dans les cliniques de la ville notamment
qui trait le flux continu de soldats
amputés il serait au moins 50000 depuis
2022 je ne me rappelle pas comment
c'était d'apprendre à marcher enfant
mais c'était quelque chose de naturel
avoir une jambe artificielle c'est autre
chose vil éta des mineurs lors d'une
opération il est touché par un tir de
sniper sa jambe gauche n'a pu être
sauvée tout à coup boum je me suis
demandé est-ce que j'ai marché sur une
mine c'était impossible on était sur un
chemin sûr que nous venions d'emprunter
ça ne pouvait pas arriver ensuite je
tombe et je vois que ma jambe n'est plus
là au prix de lourds sacrifices
l'Ukraine plie mais ne romp pas jusqu'à
quand les officiels du pays s'alarmment
le manque de munition est patent et le
soutien des Occidentaux est au plus bas
depuis le début du
conflit c'est dans ce contexte que le
président de la commission de la défense
du Sénat arrive en Ukraine après 14h de
train de nuit depuis la Pologne Cédric
Perin vient porter le message de la
diplomatie française l'Hexagone
n'abandonnera pas son allié ukrainien
c'est aux pores de chez nous donc l'idée
c'est vraiment de sensibiliser les uns
et les autres à la nécessité de
continuer à être solidaire avec
l'Ukraine de continuer à penser que sans
sans les sans une aide européenne sans
une aide occidentale plus globalement
les Ukrainiens seront évidemment en très
grande difficulté arrivé à Kief le
sénateur enchaîne les rendez-vous
officiels au pas de course ici à la Rada
le Parlement ukrainien transformé en
bnker son président Rouslan Stéphan chou
n'a qu'une idée en tête réclamer plus de
munition au
français nous manquons de pièces
d'artillerie de M
de pièces de défense anti-aérienne des
avions donc tout ce qui peut garantir un
avantage technologique à l'Ukraine dans
cette guerre d'usure que la Russie
cherche à nous imposer mais qui est
complètement à notre désavantage message
reçu les parlementaires français
porteront cette voie à leur retour à
Paris avec le sentiment qu'il est urgent
d'agir CR pukraine c'est un pays dans
une situation de guerre qui se bat avec
des moyens dont on peut considérer qu'il
sont asymétriques c'estàd qu'on c'est
pas contre une des meilleures armées au
monde l'armée russe et avec des moyens
gigantesques je crois qu'il faut
continuer à prendre à prendre conscience
que sans aide de l'Union européenne sans
aide des pays européens sans aide de la
France sans aide des États-Unis ils
perdront l'Ukraine attend plus que
jamais le déblocage de 50 milliards
d'euros par l'Union européenne mais
surtout les 61 milliards promis par les
États-Unis selon un récent sondage près
de 9 Ukrainiens sur 10 sont convaincus
qu'avec une aide suffisante de
l'Occident il pourront infliger de
sérieux revers à la Russie l'Ukraine
peut-elle encore gagner cette guerre
contre la Russie on répond à cette
question avec Lucas auin bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directeur de
recherche à l'Institut de relations
internationales et et stratégique et
auteur de ce livre géopolitique de la
Russie aux édition La Découverte Mariana
peré benessou bonsoir et bienvenue êtes
journaliste franco-ukrainienne
j'accueille également Emmanuel dupu
bonsoir bienvenue président de
l'Institut prospective et sécurité en
Europe et enseignant en géopolitique
éilie zapsk évidemment est rester à mes
côtésitorialist pour pour sens public je
vous propose pour commencer le le
constat d'un d'un d'un front militaire
qui est figé avec trois dates on
commence par janvier 2022 on est
évidemment avant l'invasion russe à ce
moment-là 92 % du territoire ukrainien
et contrôlé par keV 7 % par la Russie
décembre 2022 il y a 1 an un peu plus
d'un an on est à
17,48 % du territoire occupé par la
Russie 1 an après décembre 2023 il y a
quelques jours 17 47 % ça n'a quasiment
pas bougé pourquoi Lucas in l'Ukraine
n'arrive pas à regagner ses territoires
annexés par Moscou ça tient à quoi
d'abord la première idée qui vous vient
c'est quoi la première idée qui me vient
c'est déjà que on en soit là aujourd'hui
c'est quand même exceptionnel au regard
de la difficulté ukrainienne à l'origine
de la guerre au tout début ça c'est
toujours il faut toujours se souvenir de
ça c'est on avait l'armée russe aux
portes de
Kief on imaginait la plupart des
observateurs imaginaent que ça était
fini finalement de volodimir Zelenski et
cetera aujourd'hui le conflit stagne
pourquoi parce que probablement que
l'aide militaire occidentale n'est pas
suffisante évidemment
que le rapport aussi humain entre
l'Ukraine et la Russie est est inégal
hein on parle de 1 pour 3 à peu près
environ donc c'est-à-dire qu'il y a 40
millions d'habitants en Ukraine 140 je
crois 144 en Russie donc évidemment
c'est très différent la réserve d'homme
pour Vladimir Poutine est beaucoup plus
importante euh et
dans le même temps il est plus facile
pour un pays agressé de repousser
l'envahisseur aussi donc finalement
c'est cet équilibre il se joue aussi là
c'est-à-dire que on a une population
ukrainienne qui elle a envie
effectivement de repousser l'envahisseur
russe et en face on a une population
russe qui elle est peut-être un peu plus
en délicatesse face à ça on sait que
Vladimir Poutine a dû faire une
mobilisation de 100000 hommes à un
moment donné parce qu'ils ne venaient
pas deux même tout simplement cette
guerre est n'est pas forcément toujours
comprise euh de la part de la population
russe alors vous avez posé un certain
nombre de de chapitres de ce débat
évidemment l'aine internationale
évidemment le les les moyens humains
aussi on y on y reviendra Mariana
perbessou est-ce qu'il y a un décalage
entre ce que les Occidentaux ont promis
et ce qui est
arrivé il y a déjà un décalage un
décalage de base de position parce que
la position des occidentaux est quand
même assez claire et nette soutenir
l'Ukraine jusqu'à la victoire par par
ailleurs enfin c'est ce qu'on dit mais
dans les fêes ce n'est pas le cas parce
que jusqu'à la victoire pour les
opérations pour les offensives pour que
il soit vraiment efficace mais il en
faut beaucoup plus et surtout ces armes
il ne faut pas qu'iles soient en
quelque sorte par exemple ce que on a
parlé de la de la symétrie entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine tout à l'heure du
fait que défendre et attaquer ce n'est
pas la même chose la Russie par exemple
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait c'est très
important elle frappe les arrières de
l'Ukraine en essayant
de toucher les entrepôts des centres
logistiques ainsi de suite c'est
extrêmement important l'Ukraine on
interdit expressément à l'Ukraine de le
faire et on lui donne pas les armes de
le faire il y a des frappes ukrainiennes
sur la ville russe de Belgorod mais elle
est quoi elle est proche de la frontière
on n'est pas on est pas les frappes
ukrainiennes peuvent pas aller loin dans
le territoire russe qu'on comprenne bien
je pose volontairement une question un
peu naïve alors elle n'est pas du tout
naïve belgerot c'est une base arrière
très importante il y a il y a des n
logistiques il y a des entrepôts c'est
une sorte de plaque tournante le
problème c'est que l'Ukraine s'autorise
de frapper cette ville qui se trouve
environ à 25 km de la frontière avec les
moyens qu'elle a donc elle a encore
quelques moyens pour pouvoir le faire
mais ce n'est pas suffisant et il faut
surtout pouvoir frapper d'autres bases
il y a des bases d'entraînement par
exemple russe il y a des il a il y a qui
se trouent plus loin il faut que
l'Ukraine aussi puisse frapper par
exemple des aérodromes militaires pour
que les avions qui viennent frapper
l'Ukraine ne puissent pas décoller tout
simplement d'accord Emmanuel pourquoi il
y a ce bridage je reprends je reprends
le mot que que que vous utilisiez parce
qu' on a peur d'une escalade ensuite une
autre réaction russe alors en le disant
autrement l'Ukraine a une différence
d'approche par rapport à sa dimension
cinétique et militaire elle ne frappe
que des objectifs militaires oui donc il
est pas question de frapper la
population civile de belalgorod ou dans
la profondeur russe elle frappe des a
ort elle essaie de mettre en difficulté
l'acheminement en homme et en matériel
qui vient sur le front pour
effectivement essayer de résister de ce
point de vue- là elle répond à la
demande des Occidentaux de ne pas
affaiblir trop la Russie mais pour lui
permettre en gros ni de gagner ni d'être
défaite et c'est là le problème c'est
qu'on a donné le strict minimum à
l'Ukraine pour résister 685 jours
aujourd'hui mais pas les moyens de
gagner ça rque parce que ça coûte coûte
déjà beaucoup d'argent de de donner à
l'Ukraine les moyens de résister c'est
pas seulement une question de centaines
de milliards de dollars les ÉtatsUnis
ont donné 111 milliards depuis
maintenant près de 2 ans euh enfin
maintenant oui pas trop bientôt près de
2 ans 22 mois déjà euh les Américains
ont in extrémist autorisé
potentiellement avant le 19 janvier
prochain les 61 milliards parlera ou de
dollars qui ont été proposés et l'Union
européenne finalement a réussi à passer
outre les PAM du vet hongrois et donc
les 50 milliards arriveront en 2000 en
2024 maintenant c'est pas seulement une
question d'argent c'est une question de
du de choix des matériaux et des
matériels manitaires dont l'Ukraine a
besoin des avions de combat des missiles
de plus longue portée actuellement il y
a tout un débat en Allemagne pour qu'il
y ait des missiles de plus longue portée
500 km on appelle ça des missiles Taurus
des missiles sol sol que actuellement
Olaf Scholz ne veut pas donner alors
qu'un certain nombre de ressources à
politique l'ancien président allemand il
y a 2 jours a dit qu'il fallait all les
donner donc c'est une question de
volonté de faire résister l'Ukraine le
au maximum mais ne pas lui donner les
moyens de recouvrer la totalité des 18 %
et quelques de territoire que la Russie
a a récupéré oui alors depuis la la la
fin de du mois de décembre on assiste à
une recrud d'esence de de frappes
aériennes russes particulièrement
meurtère qui V qui vise pardon plusieurs
villes ukrainiennes par exemple hier
matin à karif volodimir Zelenski fait le
le bil des
Vic ce matin malheureusement une
nouvelle attaque de missile a eu lieu
carquiv sa région
zapor la région de kmelinski 45
personnes ont été blessées et à l'heure
actuelle 4 person été
déc qu'est-ce que ça est-ce qu'il y
avait des villes ukrainiennes qui
n'étaient plus vis depuis longtemps qui
se sentai en quelque sorte un peu
préservé qui sont plus alors toutes les
villes ukrainiennes sont visées euh
l'ensemble des Ukrainiens vivants sur le
sol ukrainien s sent visé c'est par
ailleurs un très très grand problème
c'est pour ça qu'il y a encore beaucoup
de réfugiés qui restent en Europe
notamment les femmes avec les enfants
qui qui n'arrivent pas à à à se forcer
d'aller dans dans ce pays on peut
risquer voilà on peut risquer la mort
sous les bombes quand même tous les
jours c'est par contre c'est assez
différent c'est vrai que c'est c'est
c'est la réalité que tous les Ukrainiens
partagent mais de manière assez
différente par exemple la le danger il
est ressenti de manières
particulièrement vive dans les villes
qui sont trop proches de la Russie comme
comme kkiv ou Odessa qui est trop proche
du front de mer d'où sont aussi tirés
les missiles les villes comme mcolaïif
par exemple parce que tout simplement
une fois qu'on est attaqué il y a très
peu de temps pour réagir il y a de
villes qui
sont vraiment on vit un stress très très
chronique comme kif ou Nipro parce que
ce sont des cibles de choix qui sont
ciblé sans cesse mais après il y a des
villes dans l'ouest de l'Ukraine dans
n'importe quelle région réellement où ce
stress il n il est tout simplement plus
couvert si vous voulez plus feutré mais
pas moins difficile à vivre la guerre
quand même différemment voilà o où on
sait que on sera visé moins souvent mais
tous les jours on peut être visé et par
ailleurs je je juste je précise pour les
téléspectateurs que quand ce sont des
missiles parce qu'il y a des
différentes attaque quand c'est son dé
missile normalement c'est l'attaque
enfin c'est l'alerte pour l'ensemble du
pays HM d'accord vous voyez
contrairement au drone par exemple qui
là ça déclenche l'alerte dans la région
où ça passe euh quand ce sont certains
missiles dont on sait que leur
trajectoire est tout droit donc ça
déclenche l'alerte sur sur l'axe sur
toute la trajectoire mais quand ce sont
des attaques aériennes avec des missiles
euh c'est l'alerte pour l'ensemble du
pays ou Lucas auin quand il y a des des
des attaques aériennes c'est vrai que
c'est un peu le l'axe privilégié on va
je dis ça comme ça de par par la Russie
par laadimir Poutine depuis quelques
semaines même si ça existait déjà avant
mais il y a une recrue d'essence euh il
il y a quand même beaucoup de ces
missiles qui sont détruits notamment par
des des batteries patriotes sauf que je
disais en préparant l'émission que
chaque munition vaut minimum 2 millions
de dollars 4 enfin oui alors j'ai lu les
deux j'ai donné le minimum parce que
j'ai lu entre de et 4 donc comme comme
la fourchette est vaste bon je suis
parti de déjà c'est beaucoup on en est
où qu'est-ce qu'on sait du stock
ukrainien en la matière c'est jusqu'à
quand l'Ukraine va pouvoir se défendre
avec ses ses batteries antimissile alors
personnellement je suis pas spécialiste
militaire en revanche ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que effectivement et
c'est pour aller dans dans votre sens
depuis quelques mois depuis quelques qu
semaines plutôt on a une recrue
d'essence effectivement des attaques de
missile russes on a mes contacts en
Ukraine par exemple qui se sont remis à
poster très régulièrement justement le
fait que ça y est on revient comme au
début on va se cacher on va dans les
bunkers on est inquiet on a encore plus
de coupure d'électricité qu'avant et
cetera donc il y a vraiment cette cette
dimension là qui est de retour depuis
maintenant quelques semaines quelques
mois après on a la sensation de manière
générale que la Russie qui elle a
accentué enfin c'est pas une sensation
d'ailleurs c'est une réalité statistique
a accentué ces attaques et que
finalement l'Ukraine se défend mais de
plus en plus difficilement et là il
faudrait probablement lui apporter une
aide plus significative en la matière je
vous poser la même question mais puis
sur ces sur ces munitions c'est sont des
missiles en fait he alors le système
patriote c'est très simple il en a trois
les États-Unis en en donné un
l'Allemagne en donné un et
vraisemblablement l'Espagne en a aussi
livré un avec un petit peu plus
d'incertitude mais la question n'est pas
tellement de combien de missiles ou
antimmissiles l'Ukraine dispose c'est la
manière dont de manière euh finalement
euh permanente la Russie envoie non
seulement des drones des missiles et
tout ce qu'elle a donc ce que moi je
comprends de la stratégie russe c'est
d'épuiser ce stock de munition quand
mêmepiser cap antimissile de l'Ukraine
vous l'avez évoqué un missile patriote
coûte entre 2 et 4 millions d'euros le
système en tant que tel s'il est détruit
pour l'instant il n pas é détruit coûte
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
et évidemment c'est quelque chose que
les Ukrainiens ne peuvent pas utiliser
sur la totalité du territoire mais en
même temps pour détruire les drones qui
frappent de manière indiscriminée en
permanence quasi quotidiennement
l'Ukraine on n pas besoin d' système
patriote on a besoin d'autres systèmes
c'est pour ça que les Européens ont
proposé d'autres systèmes antiaériens le
système allemand iristé le système
crotal français enfin il y a toute une
série de de couverture de l'ENSEM
de l'espace aérien qui a priori couvre à
85 ou à 90 % les frappes mais ça veut
dire qu'il reste 10 % des frappes qui
passent bien sûrmilie ce qui est
étonnant c'est un peu on a un peu
sous-estimé justement cette force de la
Russie à la fois économique et puis
aussi militaire économique parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup de sanctions et puis
finalement on voit que l'économie russe
bah elle tient bon malgré tout ce qu'on
a dit au départ qu'elle allait être à
terre que ça allait être dramatique sur
le plan militaire aussi on avait dit au
bout d'un moment ça va être compliqué
vous vous souvenez 100000 hommes à
recruter ça va être difficile c'est
difficilement compris par la population
ce que vous avez dit et finalement
quelque part ils arrivent quand même à
mener cette guerre longue qui fatigue
qui use c'est vraiment la guerre d'usure
et pourtant Poutine en avait parlé assez
rapidement quand il a compris que ça
serait pas une guerre éclaire comme il
l'avait souhaité et que ça serait la
lenteur l'usure qui gagnerait on a
peut-être un peu sous-estimé ça et avec
cette résistance qu'on peut pas donner
on peut pas leur donner les plein
pouvoirs sur le militaire comme vous
l'avez dit on peut pas non plus on a des
exigences sur les les les répercussions
sur les civils donc ça fait beaucoup ou
on va y revenir sur l'aide l'aide
occidentale mais toujours sur ces ces
munitions ces
missile Lucas auin il y a eu une visite
enfin il y a eu deux il y a eu une
visite puis contre visite de Vladimir
Poutine à pongyang et
viceva est-ce que et donc on comprend
quand même qu'à priori il y a une partie
de ces munitions qui viennent de Corée
du Nord est-ce que il y a une forme je
sais pas quel terme employé
d'humiliation pour Poutine d'être allé
quiander des mun
là-bas comment vous qui connaissez si
bien la société russe et la politique
russeah on peut voir les choses dans
dans les deux sens en réalité c'est
qu'effectivement la Russie est
globalement dispose de moins d'alliés
disons on va dire objectif comme
l'Ukraine peut en avoir c'estàd que
l'Ukraine est évidemment soutenue
militairement économiquement par
beaucoup de pays même si de moins en
moins aujourd'hui la Russie elle compte
ses alliés objectifs d' militaire sur
les doigts d'une main en réalité on a
l'Iran on a la Corée du Nord euh
peut-être qu'il y aurait la Chine mais
on sait on n'est pas sûr euh néanmoins
cette aide en tout cas nordcoréenne elle
est efficace en réalité parce qu'elle
est très importante euh au début on
avait tendance effectivement à se moquer
à l'heure où en fait bah certes la ligne
de front stagne mais en fait l'Ukraine a
de nouveau peur finalement et en tout
cas est en difficulté comme elle ne l'a
pas été depuis assez longtemps depuis le
début de la guerre euh c'est devenu d'un
coup très sérieux donc je pense que euh
oui la Russie n'a pas autant d'allés
qu'elle l'aimerait néanmoins elle en a
quand même certains qui sont d'IS
suffisant pour pouvoir l'accompagner
dans cet effort militaire et il faut
rajouter évidemment le fait que en 2024
le budget militaire russe a été doublé
donc on se on s'achemine pour Vladimir
Poutine en tout cas sur une guerre
j'allais dire longue qu'est-ce que ça
signifie long mais en tout cas encore un
an peut-être deux peut-être TR ouais
alors effectivement la question de la de
la de la durée de la stratégie de en
Poutine je vrais qu'on se concentre
maintenant pendant quelques minutes on
va ouvrir le chapitre effectivement du
du niveau d'aide
occidental et on va commencer par
écouter le président de la République
Emmanuel Macron qui
était en visite en Jordanie donc dîner
de Noël avec les forces françaises et il
parle de la situation en Ukraine
aujourd'hui dans ce pays agressé par la
Russie
depuis le début de l'année 2022 dans
l'hiver glacial l'agression russe se
poursuit vous qui savez ce qu'est le
rapport de force vous mesurez ce que
l'on ne peut laisser faire et vous
mesurez combien nous ne pouvons laisser
la Russie
gagner quel serait le lendemain pour
nous
Européens
nousurons donc à aider les Ukrainiens ce
que nous faisons même si cela nous coûte
est déterminant pour notre sécurité
future pour notre rôle en Europe et pour
la souveraineté de cette dernière Émilie
on assiste quand même il y a les mots il
y a les y a les faits un effritement du
soutien occidental à l'Ukraine qu'est-ce
qui a changé depuis 2 ans bah il y a des
questions d'inflation il y a la crise
énergétique il y a les préoccupations
plus quotidiennes en Occident qui ont
pris le pas sur cette guerre sans
compter évidemment la concurrence d'un
autre conflit celui qui se tient au
Proche-Orient avec l'attaque d'Israël
par le Hamas le 7 octobre conséquence
directes dans les médias l'Ukraine a été
recalée au second plan dans cette
terrible compétition entre les conflits
et qu'en est-il justement de cette aide
de l'aide apportée à l'Ukraine et bien
c'est triste c'està dire mais l'aide
internationale à l'Ukraine a baissé de
90 % en un an en Europe les discussions
sont ouvertes concernant l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine mais la Hongrie fait blocage
on en parlait he contre une nouvelle
aide de 50 milliards d'euros aux
États-Unis le plus gros financire de
l'Ukraine 11 milliards les républicains
s'opposent aussi à cette aide de 61
milliards de dollars qui est proposé la
précampagne électorale pour la
présidentielle et le retour éventuel de
Donald Trump très opposé au soutien à
l'Ukraine change la donne les républi
blain s'oppose systématiquement à ce que
propose l'administration Biden un
contexte qui peut évidemment affaiblir
l'Ukraine bah oui de toute façon Poutine
mise là-dessus depuis le début du
conflit il compte sur la lcitude de
l'opinion publique occidentale il en
rajoute maintenant deslouches sur
l'invincibilité de son armée et sur sa
victoire nous avons prouvé à mainte
reprise que nous pouvons résoudre les
tâches les plus difficiles et que nous
ne reculerons jamais a-t-il ainsi
déclaré dans son discours du nouvel an
en face on a un Zelenski qui fait tout
ce qu'il peut pour être entendu lors
d'une visite en Norvège mi-décembre il a
dit on ne peut pas gagner sans aide mais
finalement l'impact de sa communication
actuellement est plutôt réduit à sa
population alors chose positive les
Ukrainiens sont même plus nombreux qu'en
2022 à penser que leur pays regagnera
l'ensemble du territoires à l'issu du
conflit mais à l'extérieur en Occident
se maîre de la communication perd petit
à petit du terrain Emmanuel dupu on va
commencer par les États-Unis parce que
ce sont les premiers fournisseurs
d'armes à à l'Ukraine est-ce qu'ils
peuvent soutenir à la fois l'Ukraine et
et Israël est-ce que Joe Biden est
obligé d'arbitrer alors déjà la position
des républicains est pas
unanime Donald Trump est contre le
soutien ou le maintien en intensité du
soutien à l'Ukraine mais une de ses
concurrentes Nick ay qui connaît bien la
situation parce qu'elle fut ambassadrice
des États-Unis à l'ONU il y a encore
quelques heures à rappeler pourquoi il
fallait soutenir l'Ukraine premièrement
en disant que si on soutient l'Ukraine
les États-Unis auront pas à faire front
directement à l'éventualité d'une menace
sur des pays appartiennent à l'OTAN en
l'occurrence la Pologne et la Lituanie
euh deuxème élément il faut surtout
avoir à l'esprit que c'est un double
avantage pour les Américains de
continuer à soutenir l'Ukraine puisque
60 % de l'argent qui est donné à
l'Ukraine revient en emploi sur le
territoire américain et alors que va se
tenir une élection le 5 novembre
prochain c'est déterminant dans un
certain nombre d'États qui peuvent
basculer du côté républicain ou du côté
démocrate et donc les industriels de
défense jouent beaucoup sur la corde
sensible en convainquant les gouverneurs
de soutenir l'intensification du conflit
alors est-ce que les États-Unis peuvent
donner 61 milliards pour l'Ukraine 14
milliards pour les pour l'Israël il y a
un troisème élément les républicains ont
dit que c'est pas le problème de donner
de l'argent à l'Ukraine ou à à Israël
c'est de donner de l'argent pour la
sécurité des États-Unis eux-mêmes et ils
mettent en gros en perspective l'idée
que on peut défendre nos alliés mais il
faut avant tout défendre les États-Unis
contre une migration clandestine de plus
en plus forte à la enti avec le Mexique
les républicains l'ont dit ou enfin
c'est pas c'est pas les mêmes moyens
quoi bah si c'est 14 milliards 14
milliards exct mais oui en terme
d'arence c'est exactement la même chose
et les républicains ont cette formule en
disant on protège d'abord le continent
américain et ensuite on donnera l'argent
pour l'Ukraine le problème c'est que
l'Ukraine ne peut pas attendre car elle
mène une guerre au
quotidien le ministre de la Défense
russeou il y a quelques jours a évoqué
le fait qu'il aurait eu 25000 victimes
58000 pr en étant très précis trop sans
doute exagérément précis 58000
équipements Ukrainiens qui ont été qui
ont été détruits et en même temps la
Russie a elle un potentiel de
capacitaire et humain qui est absolument
exponentiel je termine d'une phrase la
Russie est rentrée en économie de guerre
le 24 février nous ne sommes pas rentrés
en économie de guerreou et c'est sans
doute cela le problème c'est que nous
n'avons pas livré la totalité des
munitions que nous avons promis à
l'Ukraine h Lucas Aubin si on se
projette Vladimir Poutine on imagine
qu'il Paris sur une victoire de Donald
Trump en novembre prochain il va aussi
tenter de peser sur ce scrutin d'après
vous voà moi j'ai en tête les trolls
lesines à et ce et ce oui très
probablement il il y a ce qu'on appelle
la guerre hybride c'estàd c'est la
guerre menée par d'autres moyens on sait
que Vladimir Poutine affectionne ce type
de guerre il le fait depuis depuis des
années les d' usine à troll vous l'avez
rappelé effectivement de manière
générale la guerre informationnelle est
quelque chose qui que que que que
Vladimir Poutine utilise très souvent
euh après on sait aussi que ça n'a pas
forcément un impact significatif sur les
scrutinsin il y a beaucoup d'études qui
ont montré notamment que Donald Trump
lors de sa première élection n'a pas eu
besoin de Vladimir Poutine pour être élu
même s'il y a eu ces opérations par
contre elles ont existé c'est vrai donc
probablement qu'il y en aura là euh
Vladimir Poutine lui sa stratégie c'est
de parer de toute façon sur le temps le
temps long euh on le sait depuis le
début il parie sur la désunion de
l'Occident il parie sur certaines
faiblesses supposé des démocraties à
savoir des alternances politiques et
donc de fait des choix euh qui
pourraient varier soutien ou non à
l'Ukraine soutien ou non à la Russie et
cetera euh évidemment bien malin celui
qui sait de quoi demain sera fait mais
en tout cas c'est ça stratégie et c'est
pour ça que cette désunion désunions
actuelle de l'Occident en tout cas le
fait que les moyens mis en œuvre pour
soutenir l'Ukraine soit moins important
vont effectivement dans dans son sens et
le favorisme ouis mari P le le temps
joue en faveur de la Russie c'est c'est
est-ce que vous le ressentez comme
ça le temps joue toujours en faveur de
la Russie dans la mesure où où l'action
russe s'inscrit toujours dans le temps
elle est toujours stratégique il y a
toujours des scénarios qui sont mis en
place pour durer longtemps euh ce qui
n'est pas notre cas hein ça ça la
première chose la deuxième chose euh on
on il y a il y a des forces politique il
faut voir des experts qui s'extasient
devant une sorte de pensée stratégique
de Vladimir Poutine et n'est rien il est
il n'est pas si brillant que ça loin de
là par contre ce qu'il a pour lui c'est
que il ne vit pas dans une société
démocratique et libre donc il peut se
permettre de se donner le temps qu'il
veut le temps d'action euh les les plans
les projets d'une longueur qu'il
souhaite c'est également le cas de ses
alliés de l'Iran et de la Corée du Nord
et ce qui n'est pas notre cas parce que
nous nous sommes sujets au calendrier
démocratique il y a tout le temps les
débats et les réévaluations d'un no
société donc en fait lui même s' pas eu
d'élection générale à cause de la guerre
en Ukraine ce qui est quand même aussi
aussi une question donc Vladimir Poutine
et ses alliés parce que il faut quand
même prendre
la la situation dans sa dimension
globale table de manière générale
toujours sur le fait que les
opportunités électorales que ça soit en
Ukraine donc dans les pays cibles ou que
ça soit chez les alliés à part
apporteront des opportunités pour
affaiblir la proie pour affaiblir les
Alliés donc dans ce
sens-là pour l'instant le temps joue
pour la Russie mais ça ne veut pas dire
que c'est une fatalité il nous suffit
tout simplement d'avoir une STR
stratégie claire et de l'appliquer quel
que soit euh nos nos essances
électorales alors dans dans dans ce
chapitre là sur le le l'aide occidentale
il y a on a on a commencé par le les
États-Unis alors c'est beaucoup plus
symbolique mais c'est quand même
important il y a aussi la la procédure
l'ouverture de la procédure d'adhésion
de l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne
évidemment parmi les les critères il y a
beaucoup de critères il a il y a la
question de la lutte contre la
corruption je vous propose d'écouter un
constat qui est fait par une Ukrainienne
directrice du bureau européen
antiorruption à Kief voilà ce qu'elle
dit je dirais que ce qui est le plus
sensible et qui touche tout les citoyens
c'est la corruption des dirigeants à
haut niveau quand on voit des affaires
d'argent de l'État qui a été détourné
alors qu'il aurait par exemple pu servir
à l'EFF de guerre à reconstruire des
écoles ou des logements pour des gens
qui seraient à la rue à cause de la
guerre
Emmanuel DUP c'est c'est l'un l'une des
questions en suspens
pas la seule elle est importante ce
processus il est uniquement symbolique
il va on le sait prendre beaucoup de
temps non il est déterminant vanen s'est
rendu plusieurs fois à Kief si ou se
fois si je ne m'abuse en
rappelantsk que l'Union européenne
serait convaincu de la pertinence
d'accélérer ou en tout cas de regarder
avec beaucoup enfin avec une certaine
forme de transparence le processus
d'adhésion si la question de la
corruption était réglé je rappelle qu'un
ancien ministre la défense a été limogé
car alors que ce combattait ces troupes
un certain nombre de de de procès était
ouvert par rapport à la gabgie de auquel
il avait procédé c'est d'autant plus
intéressant que le processus électoral
sera planétaire en 2024 je rappelle
qu'il a 56 pays qui vont voter il ser il
y a plus de la moitié de l'humanité près
de 4 milliards d'habitants qui vont
voter et et pas des petits pays la
Russie d'un côté les États-Unis je vous
l'accord de la Russie ce sera un vote
tout à fait symbolique mais aux
États-Unis ça pèsera mais surtout il y a
l'Inde aussi en surtout en Europe
surtout en Europe un certain nombre de
pays auront à déterminer si leur pays va
continuer à aider de manière
significative l'Ukraine vous évoquez
tout à l'heure le fait que les
États-Unis étaient le plus grand
protecteur au sens militaire du terme
pas tant que ça au terme du PIB la
France et l'Allemagne donnent davantage
que la Grande-Bretagne et les États-Unis
et les champions sont les pays baltes or
les pays baltes vont voter et il y aura
des élections importantes où un certain
nombre de partis populistes vont sans
doute revenir au pouvoir en Autriche en
octobre peut-être vont regagner de la
légitimité à l'occasion des élections
européennes donc c'est particulèrement
déterminant que l'Ukraine donne les bons
signaux et c'est d'autant plus
déterminant comme vous le disiez fort
justement qu'il n'y aura pas de
d'élection cette année ce qui aurait pu
permettre de montrer que c'est les
Ukrainiens qui luttent contre la Russie
et pas seulement le Président zeninsk il
y a d'autres forces politiques l'ancien
président porosenko le maire de Kief
Vitalie klichko et donc c'est
effectivement un signal qui est pas
forcément si positif que ça pour montrer
qu'il y a une cohésion ukrainienne face
à le Russie un mot là-dessus il nous
reste un thème important je voudrais
vous entendre lu est-ce que c'est pas
une erreur de ou est-ce que c'était
impossible d'organiser ces élections
générales en Ukraine c'est c'est
difficile à dire à la fois on comprend
tout à fait pourquoi il a refusé qu'elle
se tienne en fait on est sous la loi
martiale il y a vous l'avez rappelé 17
18 % du territoire ukrainien qui est
occupé qui ne peut donc pas voter euh et
l'effort de guerre est évidemment
primordial avant toute chose après
peut-être que voladimir Zelenski s'est
aussi privé d'un moyen miroir en fait
parce que ces élections auraient eu lieu
à peu près en même temps que les
élections en Russie euh il aurait
peut-être pu montrer que le processus
démocratique en Ukraine était davantage
respecté c'était c'est vrai c'était vrai
avant la guerre probablement que ça le
sera encore après euh par rapport à la
Russie pour Vladimir Poutine lui on le
sait son enjeu c'est de montrer que
voilà c'est c'est il vit dans une
démocratie de plébiscite donc il
s'attend à ce que la population il
espère ça ce n'est pas une certitude que
la population russe aille votter
évidemment pour lui puisque l'opposition
réelle n'existe pas vraiment aujourd'hui
en Russie donc son enjeu il est là
est-ce queil va réussir mais on aura
vraiment le chiffre de la participation
on pourra évaluer ça oui ça on pour on
pourra l'évaluer il y a encore des
institut ENF il y en a un notamment l'
institut de sondage levada qui est
plutôt que qui qu'on peut encore croire
aujourd'hui donc on va on va savoir en
fait si la population va se déplacer ou
non après il y a tout un tas de méthodes
en Russie pour aussi faire voter les
gens on l'a vu lors des dernières
élections avec effectivement des des des
hommes politiques qui descendent en bas
des des des tours d'immeubles pour en
échange de quelques roubles faire voter
les babouchcad de de du quartier en fait
et donc ça ça a existé ça va
probablement exister lors de la
prochaine élection alors dernier thème
dernier chapitre dans dans ce débat la
la la capacité de l'Ukraine à mobiliser
des troupes on en parle tout de suite
avec Tam tranu qui va nous nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau euh rebonsoir
euh Tam le gouvernement mise sur une
nouvelle loi c'est ça bonsoir Oui euh
car l'armée ukrainienne compte
aujourd'hui 850000 hommes et selon des
sources américaines qui sont les seules
sources considérées comme fiables sur le
sujet il y aurait eu 70000 morts depuis
le début de la guerre 120000 blessés je
précise que ce sont des chiffres qui
datent de l'été dernier donc ça a dû
évoluer depuis mais quoi qu'il en soit
recruté en masse en 2024 et donc
aujourd'hui un objectif affiché très
clairement par l'armée ukrainienne c'est
ce qu' expliqué m-décembre volodimir
zensk
écoutez ils ont parlé de la défense de
notre état et des contreoffensifes
potentiels du déficit et leur
proposition inclu la mobilisation de 400
à personnes
supplémentaires un chiffre très sérieux
j'ai indiqué que j'avais besoin de plus
de
preuves alors l'en c'est ce que lui
demandait l'armée ukrainienne exactement
c'est ce que lui demande l'armée
ukrainienne l'enjeu il est important car
il faut à la fois et bien remplacer les
hommes morts et les blessés il faut
créer de nouvelles brigades et surtout
mettre en place des rotations pour
remplacer ceux qui se battent depuis 2
ans pour qu'ils puissent rentrer chez
eux et pour cela et bien il y a un
projet de loi qui a été présenté en
Conseil des ministres au mois de
décembre actuellement examiné à la Rada
il prévoit notamment d'abaisser l'âge
des mobilisables de 27 à 25 ans il
prévoit également d'accroître les
sanctions contre les réfractaires on
parle de les privés par exemple de
permis de conduire d'interdire leur
transaction immobilièr et puis il y a en
revanche l'idée de limiter le service en
temps de guerre à 36 mois alors
qu'aujourd'hui et bien la durée elle est
illimitée et comment les Ukrainiens
réagissent à ces à ces propositions ils
sont complètement partagés écoutez c'est
action dans les rues de
Kief on va voir tout de suite les
réactions dans les rues de Kief on
l'espère en tout
cas alors
manifestement voilà je vois des gens qui
veulent l'éviter par n'importe quelle
méthode n'importe quel moyen ils partent
se cachent pourquoi certains doivent-ils
se battre et d'autres non s'il s'agit
d'une question de sécurité nationale
tout le monde devrait y participer tous
les résidents du pays tous les citoyens
je suis contre toute sanction sévère par
exemple la confiscation des biens des
cartes des cartes de crédit et cetera je
suis totalement opposé à de telles
sanctions dans sa forme originale la loi
a été dure peut-être sera-t-elle un peu
plus douce le fait est que la
mobilisation en tant que telle n'apporte
ni santé ni joie à personne mais
seulement la guerre donc vous l'avez
entendu on voit des Ukrainiens qui sont
partagés qui n'ont pas tous le même avis
même si bien sûr et bien l'enthousiasme
des début c'est largement affaibli les
Ukrainiens notamment le dernier qui
resta encore prudent sur ce texte car de
nombreux parlementaires ont promis de
l'amender de le modifier alors justement
il est débattu à H clos ce texte depuis
le 4 janvier que que proposent les
députés euh on sait qu'il y a de
nombreuses proposition que ces
propositions et bien elles sont très
loin d'être consensuelles il y a par
exemple une parlementaire du parti
présidentiel qui a proposé d'exonérer de
mobilisation contre un don important
fait au budget ce qui a fait grincer
bien des dents sur l'idée que la guerre
c'est donc seulement pour les pauvres un
autre a proposé par exemple le tirage au
sort et puis il y a aussi eu des
propositions pour que les Ukrainiens de
l'étranger rentrent combattre ça reste
en tout cas le grand flou hein sur ce
texte qui peut advenir pour améliorer la
cons la conscription alors que l'élan de
2022 paraît bien loin et que l'enjeu est
pourtant essentiel il y a un officier
respecté le colonel yeven mejevikin qui
a expliqué fin décembre qu'une
mobilisation insuffisante serait
synonyme fin 2024 de défaite militaire
merci Tam pour pour toutes ces
informations je rappelle le chiffre
cette cette demande des des des généraux
450 à 500000 personnes
supplémentaire Mariana pou c'est est-ce
que on a parlé de l'aide occidentale
est-ce que finalement le vote de cette
loi est pas aussi importante ou plus
importante que l'aide occidentale pour
gagner cette guerre alors elle est c'est
un sujet extrêmement extrêmement
important parce que bien entendu il faut
bien une armée capable et efficace pour
pouvoir manier ses armes c'est même pour
cela qu'il y a ce n'est pas forcément
parce que les choses vont mal mais il
faut absolument pouvoir mobiliser et
former plus de soldats pourquoi parce
que ceux qui sont actuellement au front
je rappelle tout simplement que ceux qui
sont au front c'est ceux qui avaient
déjà au moment de l'invasion de
l'Ukraine le plus gros c'était ceux qui
avaient déjà l'expérience de combat donc
ceux qui ont déjà servi depuis
2014 jusqu'à 2022 y compris dans le
donbas c'est même pour cela la société
ukrainienne finalement elle a un
consensus c'est que doivent se combattre
ceux qui ont l'expérience et ceux qui
sont les plus motivés sauf que là ça
suffit plus sauf que ceux ceux qui sont
les plus motivés et ceux qui ont
beaucoup d'expérience c la fait 2 ans
qu'ils vivent avec une sorte de régime
de relève pas de rotation de rélèv
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont des
euh ils ont des congés extrêmement
courts non ils ne peuvent même pas
rentrer chez eux ils restent dans la
région ils restent le plus souvent dans
la région où ils sont stationnés où ils
peuvent voir leurs famille qui viennent
les voir donc ça dure quelques jours il
faut vraiment que ces gens-là attention
ils ne veulent pas rentrer chez eux et
oublier la guerre pour toujours mais ils
veulent pouvoir rentrer chez eux ne
serait-ce que pour un mois pour 2 mois
voir leur maison passer du temps chez
eux il est absolument important donc
crucial et c'est même le la demande
l'exigence de la société à ce que les
héros parce que ils sont considérés
comme les héros puissent rentrer chez
eux et se réposer mais pour pose alors
la question et en fait c'est pas
question remplace est-ce qu'on les
remplace par par des hommes qui sont
moins des femmes qui sont moins formées
moins prêt à la guerre exactement et
c'est c'est pour ça que je je fais
tellement je mets tellement l'accent
qu'en fait ce n'est pas un dilemme
devolodé merzelenski lui-même ou de de
député en fait c'est le dilemme de la
toute la société
ukraen qui sent que ça serait justice
oui mais qu' on ne sait pas encore très
bien quoi faires rapide là-dessus et
ensuite on parle de la de la société
russe parce qu'il y a des choses à dire
aussi oui alors dans tout conflit
moderne la masse ça compte et de ce
point de vue-là la Russie peut
bénéficier davantage d'hommes d'ailleurs
le président russe a évoqué l'arrivée
imminent de 170000 nouveaux conscrits
une augmentation de 15 % de l'effectif
mais l'autre dilemme et l'autre paradoxe
c'est qu'il faut pas forcément des
hommes qui ne maîtrisent pas les mat les
matériels militaires l'armée ukrainienne
a changé de nature les matériels qui lui
ont été livrés doivent être euh utilisé
à bon ent avec une formation spécifique
qui se fait en dehors de l'Ukraine pour
la plupart et donc c'est pas tellement
le nombre de personnes mais c'est les
officiers et les sous-officiers et les
militaires aguéris et c'est là la
difficulté puisque les premiers sont
tombés malheureusement dans les premiers
mois de ce conflit comme promis côté
russe est-ce qu'il y a une contestation
qui qui s'exprime malgré tout a si oui
comment euh alors il y en a
effectivement il y a des formes de
contestation mais et elles sont assez
minimes quand même il faut bien le
garder en tête mais j'en vois deux moi
personnellement c'est donc d'une part
les femmes de soldats ou les maires de
soldats qui se mobilisent de façon assez
éparce mais quand même irrégulière mais
quand même depuis le début de la guerre
on les voit régulièrement demander à
Vladimir Poutine justement davantage de
soutien davantage d'aide le retour des
corps et caè et le deuxième c'est ce
qu'on appelle les minorités ethniques
non russes situé dans les républiques
que ce soit en tchenie en bouryati au
Tatarstan par exemple qui parfois ne
comprennent pas non plus cette guerre
pas pour les mêmes raisons que les
maires ou les femmes de soldat mais
parce que évidemment on on soutient
souvent que c'est une guerre slave et
évidemment un bourriat un chechenen ou
un tata se sent probablement moins
concerné néanmoins ces contestations là
sont assez euh pour le moment minime par
rapport à l'ensemble de la société russe
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat Luca auin votre
livre géopolitique de la Russie publié
aux éditions de La Découverte voilà
c'est la fin de ce sens public je vous
dis à demain 18h et 22h et puis notterz
que la matinale de Public Sénat reprend
demain 7h30 9h l'invité politique
Doriane monsini en direct à 8h ce sera
Geoffre idier le secrétaire général
délégué du parti LR député européen
belle
[Musique]
soirée